y en directo a vamos hasta perú para
hablar con nuestro corresponsal
francisco zacarías sobre la
comparecencia del presidente pedro
castillo ante la fiscalía el mandatario
acudió para responder por presuntos
delitos de corrupción y negó las
imputaciones en su contra a través de su
cuenta de twitter dijo que siempre daría
la cara y que colaboraría con la
justicia francisco buenas noches
cuéntenos cuál fue la actitud del
presidente de pedro castillo en la
comparecencia ante la fiscalía
buenas noches la indigencia duró más de
dos horas y nuevamente el presidente
pedro castillo se acogió a su derecho de
guardar silencio eso es lo que le están
recomendando sus abogados callar por
ahora y pedir una nueva citación al
ministerio público cuando éste tenga
toda la información en su contra pero
según algunos juristas esta estrategia
podría ser interpretada como una corte
como un indicio de culpabilidad al salir
de la fiscalía rodeado por un fuerte
cordón de seguridad pedro castillo
señaló que atender a todas las
situaciones en la fiscalía para declarar
siempre vamos a dar la cara dijo el
mandatario con megáfono en mano ante un
grupo de manifestantes que se
congregaron para expresarle su apoyo el
pedro castillo rechazó todas las
acusaciones y se mostró confiado según
señaló de demostrar su inocencia ante la
justicia
francisco qué tan complicada se está
poniendo la situación jurídica del
mandatario y su entorno
pedro casi no tiene una situación muy
difícil porque la fiscal general del
perú patricia benavides acaba de incluir
al primer ministro aníbal torres así
también como al ministro de justicia
félix cero en la investigación por
presunta corrupción luego que el
ministerio público ha señalado que
existen indicios de encubrimiento y de
organización criminal por otra parte una
corte está evaluando un pedido de
impedimento de salida del país por 36
meses contra la primera dama a línea
paredes la fiscalía está señalando que
la esposa del presidente pedro castillo
sería parte de una organización criminal
y mientras tanto el congreso de perú se
prepara para presentar la censura y
obligar la renuncia del ministro de
trasportes general alvarado quien viene
siendo investigado por presunta
corrupción en realidad este es un camino
muy difícil que tiene que transitar el
presidente pedro castillo
cosa y sus ministros